so as you guys know the coverage of
Deadpool related content is my chance to
cast aside the serious nature of my
videos and have some fun in this
instance we're going to have a
conversation about how Deadpool became
Ironman and cause one of the worst
environmental disasters in the history
of Marvel Comics
so the story of deadpool becoming iron
man actually opens up in 1985 at the
Daily Bugle depicting a comic and a
manner almost identical to the way
comics were drawn during this time
writers Jerry Duggan and Brian Posehn
bring us a scenario of business as usual
with spider-man's nemesis vulture having
previously committed a crime in Harlem
Oscorp dealing in illegal arms trading
and Stark Industries in the middle of a
hostile takeover
whilst Archie sits in a drunken state
allowing his company to go to pieces now
in the main Marvel continuity Albert
Einstein had actually launched a hostile
takeover and alcoholism was a major part
of Starks life and because this story
takes place in Deadpool volume 3 issue
number 7 we can largely assume that this
is in the mainstream continuity well the
writers don't really clarify this seems
to be true of the fact the Flash
Thompson is still being a dick what I
mean here is that when he parks in a
handicapped spot when Peter tells them
it's the wrong thing to do Flash simply
replies that legless people shouldn't be
able to get all the good parking spots
however in the midst of Peter lecturing
flash Deadpool simply appears with no
explanation of how we got there now in
truth it would be fully it would be
foolish of us to ask such a ridiculous
question since the answer is clearly
just reasons but the fact remains the
Deadpool Jack's Flash's car Hotwire's it
and drives off claiming that claiming
that stealing the car from a handicapped
spot is okay because he's mentally
handicapped and so we're flat and so her
Flash Thompson shows up screaming for
someone to stop Deadpool and Peter
simply lets Deadpool drive off leaving
flash to deal with the consequences of
being a jerk the following this where
Deadpool seems to be driving around
without any real purpose and stole
Flash's car for the fun of it
during his drive he almost hits and
kills the power pack now what we have to
stuff into the misfortune of knowing
that they survived duggan actually takes
a bit of a potshot here with regards to
their title what I mean is that power
pack was Marvel's attempt to tap into
the preteen audience during the 1980s by
having a title centering on a team of
children including Franklin Richards all
of whom had powers well the title was
moderately successful lasting 60 issues
until 1991 the cancellation of power
pack solo run was actually due to poor
sales something used when Deadpool makes
the
they doesn't have to kill them off since
her failing title will do it for him
however in the midst of making fun of
the powerpack and their crappy comics
Deadpool receives a visit from a man
named Vitas Esquire now this character
was actually created explicitly for this
story and where his role in the Marvel
Universe will be provided it won't be
done in this comic and so to round
things out of it Vitas is a demon from
the realm of Mephisto who would travel
the world may patch with mortals for the
purpose of spreading demonic power and
then feed on that power with the
intention of overthrowing Mephisto while
his efforts would fail and he would be
killed by Mephisto this particular comic
introduces character by having them form
a pact with Deadpool for the purpose of
keeping Ironman drunk and in return
Deadpool would get a laser disc factory
now for those of you who don't
understand why this is such a big deal
wide my advice is to go watch Blade
Runner on laserdisc if after seeing it
you walk away still unsure of why laser
discs matter then there's absolutely no
hope for you but continuing on Deadpool
goes on a mission to find alcohol and
after walking into a liquor store he
comes across a head it comes across a
hip you jacking the place after having
killed the store owner now where the
hippie makes the claim that the store
owner cut himself shaving I'm actually
inclined to believe in the reason why
the reason why is because I shaved with
a straight razor once and cut myself so
I could easily see how this might happen
and so after distracting a hippie with
some bottles of partytime fruit liqueur
which is a comic stand-in for Mad Dog
2020 a well-known bum wine it sells for
399 a bottle down at pickles
Deadpool which it actually does dip will
get me Deadpool kills the hippy owing to
the fact but taking someone to jail is
simply too time-consuming after which he
leaves the store with a giant bag of
alcohol from here we transitioned to
Hotel Flom in Los Angeles and Tony Stark
sitting drunk watching Howard the Duck
while in the middle of a stupor with
Deadpool busing end of the room claiming
to be room service when the Rouge
doesn't go over
he simply presents himself as the
Deadpool furthermore were stark as how
Deadpool was able to find him when Wade
states that Stark left Clues a bit of
banter ensues regarding stark leaving a
giant Iron Man shaped hole in the wall
now we're Deadpool was supposed to keep
start supply with alcohol and drunk for
some reason beyond me he suddenly
develops a conscience leading him to
have second thoughts about a world
without Ironman and so after coaching
start out of his alcoholism and helping
him get his life back together in the
middle of poor in their alcohol down the
drain
how are the duck is interrupted by a
news broadcast stating that a power
plant is overheating due to the
generators failing resulting in a China
Syndrome now to provide a bit of clarity
the China Syndrome is a metaphor used to
describe a scenario where the core of a
nuclear reactor heats up to the point
that it burns through its containment
vessel the housing building and
eventually the crust of the earth the
term China Syndrome comes from an
archaic joke that the United States and
China are on opposite sides of the earth
meaning that the core would burn through
the crust of the planet fall through its
core and out of the other side into
China while this is clearly nonsense and
that this wouldn't happen
the term is meant to indicate a
situation where the breach is so severe
that virtually nothing can stop it and
so after knocking stark over the head
with a bottle of liquor spray-painted
the Iron Man helmet to match his face
and donning the suit
Deadpool takes off to the scene of the
meltdown of the Avengers most as the
Avengers most intoxicated hero and so
arriving on the scene of the meltdown
and speaking with the nuclear technician
on site since the nuclear rods serve the
purpose of keeping the core from
overheating with a lack of coolant the
rods are allowing it to overheat and so
when the technicians suggest using
seawater as a way to cool the rods
Deadpool misunderstands and as a result
takes the rods and throws them into the
ocean now this is probably the horse big
dead bull could have done then the
reason why is because this nuclear power
plant was located on the Pacific Coast
Highway which is a stretch of water
running along San Francisco Santa Monica
and Santa Cruz and so Deadpool had
essentially made this water undrinkable
and the sea life inedible and now the
water has been poisoned with nuclear
radiation as a result he gets an earful
from Tony Stark and that they'll be
cleaning out the Pacific host
as a result he gets an earful from Tony
Stark's dating but they'll be cleaning
up the Pacific Coast Highway for years
do his actions as garvik is amazing in
addition to this where Vitas makes his
return and anger over the fact that
Deadpool seemed he'll the loud start to
become sober
Wade argues that when a contract was
signed it stipulated that Ironman needed
to be drunk in stay drunk not Tony Stark
to this end when Deadpool developed a
conscience and decided that the nuclear
power plant needed to be saved because
Stark was in no physical condition to
act
Deadpool upheld the bargain by getting
drunk dressing in the Ironman suit
fine to the scene saving the nuclear
power plant albeit irradiating the
Pacific Ocean in the process and so
consequently with no recourse for waged
argument the Fisto appears taking Vitas
back to hell on the grounds then not
only was he tricked by Immortal but have
been plotting against Mephisto himself
by enticing bargains with mortals and
being unable to show anything for it and
so the story comes to a close cable Sun
cable suddenly appears out of nowhere I
don't know why we cable suddenly appears
wearing Doc Brown's spaghetti strainer
hat from Back to the Future claiming the
Deadpool needs to travel with him for
the purpose of stopping senior sinister
but and the Mexican brother of mr.
sinister and in that if they fail a
messiah war will break out resulting in
a mutated legacy virus that infects the
x-men leading to Deadpool joining cable
and travelling back to the future with
that being said we're going to bring
this video to an end I hope you guys
enjoyed it this is why I love Deadpool
stories because I get to just kind of
cut loose and have some fun and yeah so
I will catch you guys under peace